how much credit does President Bush
deserve for finding bin Laden this was
some controversy last was zero that's
why that's controversy command did
nothing about bin Laden until 9/11 and
after 9/11 you know he kind of did it
for a few months kind of he sent troops
into Afghanistan but didn't tell them to
get bin Laden
no it's amazing when you read the quotes
how quickly he went from we have to get
bin Laden this is our focus to six
months later I don't I don't think about
it it is going after one man you know
what what's the big deal about a flee
about that though is when you think
about all the risks that were involved
in maintaining camps for detainees when
you think about the systematic efforts
to seize enemy combatants I mean that's
obviously riskier than just killing
people on the battlefield and I wonder I
mean it does seem as though they were
trying to get a systematic picture of
the organization in order to make steady
progress and eliminating its leadership
so I'm he took assets that we're looking
for bin Laden in Afghanistan yeah he
took them I think we can all agreed that
was a mistake but the thing is that they
were still seizing enemy combatants they
were still fairly active the mistake
that wasn't a mistake a mistake is you
know oops I parked the car and they're
in the carry you're absolutely right it
deserves to be condemned it was a
foreign policy blunder on the historic
scale there you go but it's also good
parrot it's also works you know why
would they have seized these commands
why would they have systematically tried
to gain a picture of what the
organization was like I mean that
clearly but they are you looking at
positive holding only what people that
were seized had no usable information
were kept year after year absolutely
right person cooks which is a scandal
but the thing is that he was actually
very candle it was a solicited war crime
here it was do you see why it's actually
a liability to capture people and put
them in detainee camps the way that that
would actually so when you look at the
number of drone attacks we see now it's
dramatically stepped up but the thing is
that's right and you only have drone
attacks and what the argument is that
actually a lot of those are attacking
foot soldiers rather than higher value
targets because the sense is that you
can't actually gain valuable
intelligence from there's a lot of
number three's right I think that the
issue is you know why would they have
done this thing that was actually
incredibly costly for them
diplomatically etc the organization I
believe was called Alec station or Alec
station that was a part of the CI that
was supposed to be dedicated just to
finding I think they closed it down I
never understood that I'm gonna get in
trouble for asking this question it is
above you because you'll know the answer
how much of this always luck ultimately
really you talk you don't really lock it
this is a lucky a part of it now when
you try to get someone for 15 years I
suppose luck too enters into it but the
fact is CIA was ordered 15 years ago to
get this guy and only got him in August
that's when they actually found the lead
no if you order a pizza that comes 15
years later are you gonna be happy yeah
and I would think that would be the
first to admit that there is some luck
involved yeah and also I would say
complacency on the part of the target
that's really what it was he thought he
thought he was protected right no I said
it to the to Peter Bergen last week when
I made the analogy with in The Godfather
when salaat so says the Michael Corleone
the old man got sloppy
five years ago Mike could I had gotten
to him and that's what it was well you
know he got sloppy you're kind of
refuting something that you had said
right I mean if that's true if the
sloppiness was clearly a part of this it
was something that took a very long
period of time and there were other
steps that led to this this is not to
say that the the current president
doesn't deserve a lot of credit but it's
also true that you needed to have a
picture of the organization and that
intelligence was being built it's really
well if you want to be really in the
national security bureaucracy who were
actually dedicating a lot of time and
energy to this and this was true under
the previous president this one as well
I think it's less they were dedicating a
lot of time and energy to Iraq well if
you want to be really fair though the
key to him getting sloppy was that he
was sitting under the protection of the
Pakistani government so give them credit
I think what look but think hard about
us that Pakistan is still there even
when we look away and that's some that
we often forget and we have to
understand that their resentments come
from somewhere so just to throw that out
there as the designated browndown I
agree
let me ask a question on a different
matter what do you think this is for
Andrew Ross Sorkin what do you think of
the fact that the banks that were too
big to fail during the bailout are now
too bigger to fail a point which is
brilliantly raised in the movie by the
way this will be really I'm not just
plugging it because it's on this network
but it explains what has been murky to
me for all these last couple of years
because I'm not a very good at economics
in a way that I felt like even I could
understand well thank you for that you
know my worry today is as you just said
these things are too big to fail I think
of Kubik to fail squared the top 10
banks now control 75% of all bank assets
just think about that concentration what
that ultimately means we haven't done
anything really about this all of the
legislations only around the margins and
we really need to figure out
structurally what we're willing to do
about it but to me the biggest problem I
think you saw in the movie when you talk
to and you saw it as a human drama about
people these institutions are now not
just too big to fail the too big to
manage that's the problem they're so
they're so large and and they by the way
keep getting larger and the question is
how can you physically as one person as
a CEO or a board or whatever actually
manage these institutions and that to me
I think is something that we got to look
at and nobody really talks about it look
at Andrew you know one of the
you talk about this is if we just
haven't developed the will to care or
make this happen yet but you said the
banks are fighting back and that's the
other problem we have sent an indelible
signal we have prosecuted no one who
helped destroy the American economy
Bill Black was the prosecutor in the
Savings and Loan scandal said we the the
regulator's sent thousands of referrals
to the FBI to the Justice Department for
criminal prosecution and the major
miscreants and the savings and loan
scandal went to jail these guys get more
money their bonuses are bigger their
companies are bigger they have one
I'm not sent that message oh we've sent
that message loud and clear and on the
criminal side I'm going to say something
that's gonna be unpopular and
unsatisfying this may actually be a
crime meaning a crime against everybody
that isn't actually a fraud and that and
that is part of the problem I'm not sure
probably the choirs Loans weren't frauds
well no I do I do think some of those
were fraud but there were frauds on both
sides and so it makes it much much more
complicated was when they changed the
laws dodgy rhyme the deregulation that
led to stop getting rid of glass that
was too big the larger story that's the
problem is that what they did probably
wasn't technically a crime right okay
thank you everybody Thank You panel and
gotta go
[Applause]